brah benedict cumberbatch took ten
minutes of an angle class once what's
your favorite work I like saying bagel
oh I like clam chowder chowder we are
with James Corden hi
see there's no real audience no no I
guess much if there was a big roll
oh that would be really great I mean in
my head that Shirley's go James
is the new host of The Late Late Show
he's excited about it and conserving
energy for the premiere what did you
want me to do James is the new host of
The Late Late Show I'm also having a
show on E start soon so it's very crazy
times will you come on my show and then
I'll come on your show a hundred percent
we could do some cross internet vibe the
where we in a workings of that structure
yeah you should speak at conferences
well that's my full-back because I think
we share this new hosting thing we're
gonna get a lot of positive and negative
feedbacks and I've learned from my
mother that the best way to counteract
that is by taking haters and killing
them with kindness so we're doing
something I haven't done for a long time
and that is commenting on comments in
the style what we're gonna do is praise
each commenter and then talk a little
bit about the comment okay okay Sayuri
Willis Yuri Willis Sayuri well it is
more like say you're amazing amazing you
see you're so good at this already this
[ __ ] home get rich it sprays in a way
she's even gone so far as to use a comma
punctuation good spelling appalling
[ __ ] he spelt bi CH but maybe it would
you lace it so maybe use germans i maybe
not dis big con guess we change that
actually might be the reality but i
don't think so
last time I checked Sayuri Willis it's
not a particularly German name I wonder
if he's gone yes [ __ ] can't get rich
then gone hi and I gotta remember to put
a comma after it would be really weird
if I was supposed this without a comma I
would look like an idiot men we're
beyond ecology thought to say great do
you have a stepfather kill yourself oh
so he's actually shouting yeah great
stepfather kill yourself yeah
maybe he's some kind of neurologist
mm-hmm and he can see by the outline of
the people of your EIN then you have the
very very rare disease stepfather oh and
you would be better to kill yourself
then let that disease bully take control
of me so really is trying to save me
should be trying to help my advice is
get a second opinion okay
I think Don necesita doctor and say have
I got a stepfather JD Sierra mm-hmm Jane
and steer a more like Jaden Sierra -
you're miss great soda
yes price doesn't matter I'll have a
Sierra right back Sarah misses like the
wingman it doesn't matter
we've got Sierra Mist that should be the
slogan sodas I have at you Jaden has
confused the word at I think for eight
we're all in it enough now that we know
that this means act so what she's
actually saying is I had so maybe she's
going I hurt you Oh grace I hurt you
because your work is phenomenal I took
my hat to you and the amazing work
you've done so only you've actually
ended up looking silly then you have a
wash class I can watch all this egg off
my tail right now from Alison love [ __ ]
no punctuation but a capital B difficult
to
positive spin on this is [ __ ] a
derogatory term because I think Britney
Spears it's Britney [ __ ] Britney [ __ ]
trying to pulverize an audience with
that I think that there is a certain
inflection that when used on [ __ ]
softens it yeah when it's like brought
down a little bit like I'm Britney [ __ ]
yeah it's very different if you're in
your car and someone cuts you up and you
go [ __ ] not nice
well James thank you so much for being
here what we've you know shown is that
the Internet is an incredibly positive
place yes people have given the freedom
to express themselves really I have you
absolutely make sure that you check out
the Late Late Show with James Corden
[ __ ] I'm awful at accents I will fully
admit my accents just turning to me
yelling give me a New Jersey let's go to
the mall and talk about it oh my god I
like it I want to talk about it coffee
water can't believe it Johnny
Tommy what are you doing this is crazy
man we gotta go get a pizza